>>Adam: Couple of little brief things.
We have the agenda over there.
Some things we wanted to bring
up, and we only got half-an-hour,
so do our best to use
our time efficiently.
>>Brent: When teachers talk to each
other, teachers learn from each other.
There's so many great ideas that our
teachers come up with that engage kids,
get kids to think outside of
the box that I'm just amazed
at what we can accomplish
when we work together.
>>Brent: Individuals create great ideas,
but really to move schools forward,
I believe that everyone needs
to be together and in dialoguing
with each other, and
creating a conversation
about how to best serve students.
>>Adam: I feel really fortunate that at
our school, we have grade level prep,
which means that every day all of
the sixth grade teachers are able
to discuss various topics whether
that be student concerns we have,
or how to better integrate curriculum.
>>Adam: Here is what is--
remains of the weather balloon.
We're really excited.
This actually pretty much
everything, minus the balloon itself.
>>Teachers: Oh!
[laughter]
>>Teacher: That looks good.
>>Adam: Last year, an
engineering teacher
and myself thought it'd be
really great to have a sort
of science-engineering crossover project
where we launched a high-altitude
weather balloon way
up into the stratosphere, with the
intention of getting some unique data
to help reinforce sixth grade topics
of watershed studies and whatnot.
>>Students: Three, two, one, blast!
[cheering]
>>Adam: And here is the tree it
landed on somewhere in the Klickitat.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Adam: It went somewhere in-between.
And that's what we're
going to try to show...
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Adam: ...to everyone using this data
that everyone's pawing
through right now.
>>Adam: I definitely had a pretty
clear idea in mind of what I wanted
to do upon retrieving our
weather balloon, and it was great
to bring the topic to the rest of the
team to find out how we could connect it
to language arts and
other content areas.
>>Adam: Yesterday, we were able to
make a crossover connection to math.
I was having students actually
looking through the data.
And I was trying to rack my brain about
how we might make more of a robust
like language arts connection.
That's not my strength.
I was wondering if you
guys had any ideas.
>>Teacher: You could also do a
really cool imagination piece
with the travel of that, too.
>>Teacher: I agree the
picture was traced on top
of it would tell the story.
>>Teacher: But I think it's a great way
to bring in the scientific writing, too.
I mean, you could do both.
You could take them both at this time.
>>Teacher: You could do the same
type of writing for both of them.
One would be scientific writing.
And one would be creative writing,
and basically we're inspired
by one single experience, and how could
you look at it from both perspectives?
>>Adam: That'd be cool!
>>Brent: You have to
provide the structure
for collaboration; that's essential.
You can't have collaboration if teachers
don't have time to collaborate and so
by tweaking a Master Schedule, you can
provide opportunities for collaboration.
That collaboration leads
to great things.
>>Anne Marie: Because of that common
prep time, it allows every team
to plan field trips that
allow them to figure out,
"How do we related the curriculum
within the different subject areas?"
>>Anne Marie: So we remember
we went on a field trip.
That was gathering data for helping
the kids understand science based
on where we live, and our
unique geology in The Gorge.
>>Angie: When the science teachers
decided to do this geology unit
on land formations, we saw the
opportunity as language arts teachers
to bring the idea of the legends
that explain these into reading
and language arts so they could
write a legend and then perform it.
>>Angie: And they could choose to work
alone or in partners, or in a group.
And they've done skits an
storybooks, and comic strips,
and puppet shows, and iMovies.
>>Teacher: Awesome, are
those recorded somewhere
that we could watch, or are they...?
>>Diesel: We took a trip, and
it was meant to be for science,
and then in this class, we're writing
like legends about Beacon Rock
and Wahclella Falls, and like
how Hood River Gorge came to be.
>>Anne Marie: The effect for the
kids is they hear common messages.
Rather than it being discreet classrooms
and subjects and teachers and classes.
They see it all relating together.
>>Adam: It is incredibly
important to allow teachers
to collaborate and work together.
Not only to enrich the
learning of all their students,
but ourselves as professionals.